all righty happy thursday y'all uh
thanks for joining me today um we're
just getting started it's right at uh am
central standard time for me here in
texas
but we'll wait a few minutes to let some
folks roll in
and then we'll get started on the uh our
studio team eval demo
we're going to have a bit of a live code
a little bit of slides
and definitely be taking questions as
they come up in the chat
if you do have any questions uh feel
free to drop them into the
uh youtube uh chat here um on the live
stream that you're watching
so thanks for joining me and again we'll
get started in a little bit
i'm going to go ahead and drop a few
links um into the chat so if you wanted
to follow along or wanted to get more
information you could do so give me one
second i'll drop those for you
a lot of the examples i'm using you can
find the public source code
here on my github
so that's going to have some of the
details for the slides as well as some
of the example applications we're
showing and are in python
i also have my colleagues
from our studio who will be answering
some questions so if you see me talking
and you see people answering questions
in the chat i'm lucky enough to have
some some great team members behind me
um we also have kelly o'brien who's the
pack or the our studio connect
um product manager uh so she might
answer some additional questions there
in the chat
um what we've been doing is kind of for
a lot of these is if you'd like to say
hello in the chat feel free to say hi to
each other in the chat usually it's
between you know
60 and 600 people somewhere in that
range in the group so feel free to talk
amongst yourselves or ask questions as
well
and
let me go ahead and
we're about two minutes past i'm going
to go ahead and uh start screen shooting
here in a second
i saw somebody mention that there's some
echoing so i'm just checking on that but
i think we're okay
all right so let me go ahead and kick
this off and we'll get started so i'm
going to share my whole desktop here
um
so for
today again like i mentioned there's
going to be a little bit of some slide
craft in terms of like we we go some
slides we're going to walk through but
the bulk of today is going to be walking
through the rstudio team evaluation
so the team evaluation is all three of
our professional products so rstudio
workbench our studio connect and our
studio package manager
the evaluation means that they're time
gated in terms of it it's just trying
out the products and we provide the
hosted environment for that
if you did want to try it out you just
fill out this form and you can click
start in the evaluation
and then i'll walk through what the
evaluation actually looks like how you
can use the products and then really
what today is about is
understanding how these things fit into
your workflow in an enterprise as well
as how do you make some of these
arguments for using open source even if
you're not using our professional
products we'd love for you to use them
but even if you're not going to use them
how do you you know motivate folks to
use r and python and all the wonderful
packages that you use in both languages
within your organization
so again i'll jump back into the slides
we'll talk a little bit about our studio
team and then we'll hop over into the
evaluation proper and have quite a bit
of live code and kind of walking through
the whole process
again for our studio team we think of
this as really like a single home for r
and python for all data science teams so
regardless of your 90 r 10 python or 100
python and no r or some other mix in the
middle we've tried to build these
products in a way that they're serving
both kind of constituencies that both
people are very happy and able to be
productive with these products
if you did want to follow along with the
slides you can do this so here i'm going
to drop this link in the chat as well
those are going to be available at
colorado.orgstudio.com
rsc
rstudio dash team dash prez so again
we're hosting these on our studio
connect
so kind of a good fun example there
as far as the three products if you
weren't familiar with them and kind of
the different people who would be
interested you know maybe you're a data
scientist or data analyst maybe you're a
decision maker a business user or
someone else kind of trying to make
decisions with data with data science or
maybe you're even uh an r admin or
python admin or an i.t admin that's more
concerned about
all this open source work that's being
done and people are trying to be
productive but you're trying to support
them and make things secure and scalable
and have proper operations around it
so again we kind of think of this as
these are the three core personas that
we're trying to solve problems for
in terms of data scientists really want
to use are in python they want to
develop their applications and share
them with their the rest of the
organization whether that's for other
data scientists or for business users
trying to make decisions with the data
science work they're doing
and then the it team whether you're an r
admin meaning that you're kind of in
both worlds or a python admin or a
traditional it admin you're just trying
to support all this and make things
operate smoothly
again the three products are studio
workbench our studio package manager in
our studio connect
our studio workbench is where you would
do all of your data analysis and kind of
writing your code so you can write there
in r you can write there in python you
have the rstudio
ide as well as vs code and jupyter so a
nice mix of different environments you
can write code in
our studio connect is where you'll
publish all your results so that could
be our markdown reports or jupyter
notebooks it could also be you know
interactive applications like shiny or
uh dash or flask or streamlit and python
and then lastly our studio package
manager is supporting all of those open
source libraries you can actually store
copies of them
on premise or in your cloud behind your
firewall wherever you need them as well
as your own internally developed
packages and these are going to be sent
into workbench into connect in this
process
so as far as what we're kind of focusing
on are here at our studio we're focused
on open source first in terms of we're
really trying to build an open source
model where we give away actually the
vast majority of the software we create
so things like tidy models the tidy
verse our markdown those are open source
packages that we're giving away you know
freely available to anyone who wants to
use them the professional products build
on top of those to provide some of the
things that organizations are more
interested in so security scalability
you know access control uh as well as
logging and authentication and all that
we're also focused on being code first
in terms of we really believe that to do
you know really serious data science and
do you know productive work that code is
going to make you better and then
learning even a little bit of code or
learning a lot of code can help you be a
more productive data scientist and have
more control over what you're building
and lastly centralized or even
cloud-based so this means that our
products run on a server whether that's
on premise bare metal you know existing
servers you have or in a virtual private
cloud like you might find on say aws
with amazon marketplace or azure or
google cloud or the other providers
again we're focused on r and python as
the languages of choice for these
and this will actually have r and python
code throughout the presentation today
and then as far as these i've already
talked about them but our studio
workbench our studio connect and rcu
package manager all three of those
products make up our studio team the
environment that we're talking about
today
so we'll talk about one more slide then
jump into the the live coding section
but really the problem here we're trying
to solve is that there's this chasm or
this gap between what data science teams
are doing and trying to doing and
actually impacting the business and you
know creating business value or
affecting decisions in a positive way
so data science teams create things but
it's stuck on their laptop or they're
trying to share something with their
boss or their colleague and they have to
email it to each other or they you know
have to put into a shared drive the
person downloads it and moves it over
as far as the
other portions you might actually have
automated decisions so you're trying to
actually put your models into say
production where they're interacting
with your website or working with
the you know
other software that you want to embed in
the process so how do we cross this
chasm and get the data science work that
you're doing into the hands of either
live decision makers or into the
automated decisions that people are
doing inside the software
so if there's a data scientist you're
either creating insights or trying to
share insights or creating models that
are going to be used downstream
and that's what you're doing today but
you're still trying to get them closer
to either decision makers for automated
decisions or actual human interaction
so in our world you'll be creating these
insights or writing code in r and python
in a data science workbench that
supports both languages so log in one
time you have your full environment for
r you have your full environment for
python
so with rn python you can build amazing
things you can build applications
reports apis you can send you know
programmatic emails as opposed to manual
emails there's a lot of power here in
terms of things you can build
once these things are finished you can
now get them onto a deployment server
basically a centralized location where
people want to access the things you're
creating they know to go here they go to
this location they log in it's access
controlled it automatically scales up to
meet the user needs
all the things you want there
and this will deliver the actual
applications
uh as well as you know scheduling emails
and other assets or automations that go
to live decision makers
or hosting things like api so plumber in
r or
flask or fast api in python which
integrate into other software whether
it's you know java or javascript or your
website any other type of things there
and lastly to make sure all these things
work together
the package manager actually eased in
this maintenance and reproducibility of
these environments to manage your
packages for both the workbench in terms
of where you're writing code and you're
developing assets
in your deployment server where the kind
of production app sets live
so in terms of what this looks like
again this is our studio workbench where
you're analyzing your data our studio
package manager which is supplying the
packages to workbench as well as our
studio connect and then all the amazing
open source libraries that you know and
want to use are you know the things
you're actually creating so all that
work you've already done to learn things
like jupiter or streamlit or shiny or a
markdown or pins
all these things can be published to
connect and you can work on them inside
our studio workbench
all right
so let's
hop over into the evaluation
again if you did want to do this in the
future immediately after this you can
always go to rstudio.com products team
evaluation or to search for rstudio team
evaluation and you'll be able to access
this just give us a little bit of
information and we'll send you the link
to open up your own evaluation
environment
so once you actually get an evaluation
environment this is a hosted environment
meaning that there is nothing for you to
install for the evaluation you just go
to the url and you get access to the
entire suite of our products for this
temporary environment
so you have access to our studio
workbench access to our studio connect
and our studio package manager which
make up our studio team
it's got some additional links in terms
of if you need some help or if you want
to learn a bit more about team or you
have some questions
as well as access to a built-in mail
server so you can send emails kind of
from connector uh through some of the
automations there and see how those work
so really part of the power here is that
if you wanted to evaluate how can i you
know
advocate for using these open source
tools in my organization
rather than having to download the
software install it and go through kind
of this it process you could actually
evaluate it here in your browser
show some of the work you're doing to
your colleagues or to your decision
makers or to your you know stakeholders
who own the budget or your it colleagues
and actually saying here's the things i
could be doing can we move forward and
try and make this a reality
something else to note in terms of once
you've gotten to this page
you're going to be logging into
everything with the default password and
username
i've changed the username for this
environment because i don't want anyone
to accidentally log into my environment
with with this information so i have
changed this for mine but for you if you
were to open up this environment you
could go to say our studio workbench and
it's going to have the default username
and password as our studio and our
studio so easy to remember and log in
and you can use the same credentials
inside rstudioconnect
as far as uh the next question will
probably be like okay cool like i
actually want to see this in action so
let's open up our studio workbench i'll
accept this
and you'll note that it automatically
logs me in because i've already logged
in here
if i wanted to it will come with some
you know basic examples of code but i
could always upload or write my own code
here it's a full r studio environment so
let's go ahead and open in our studio
session i'm inside rstudio team now so
it might look a little bit different
than your traditional r studio
environment
but the core idea is i can open up a new
r studio session
by clicking new session we'll say my
first session
i want to use our studio and i'll start
that up
and it'll send me over into the happy
environment that i know and love r
studio the ide
at this point you know maybe i have a
script i want to use i could always
bring it in from version control so if i
wanted to clone something from say like
a github repository i could do that
or you can actually upload files from
your desktop
so i'll go to my downloads
and i have nothing in here because i
cleared it out but i've actually
uploaded a few different things for
these examples so there's some things
about pens and some things about our
markdown and python and shiny all sorts
of different assets here that can look
at
so if you had code you wanted to upload
again please note that this is not a
production environment in terms of you
shouldn't try and use you know this
evaluation as the environment where
you're going to do all of your data
science work today but this is an
evaluation of how you could do some of
that work
um so
you can try it out here and see if you
wanted to move forward with evaluating
it say on premise or actually moving
forward with professional products
um
part of the back out here in terms of
obviously we've seen our studio i'll go
into a little bit more in terms of what
you can do there but it's more than just
our studio in terms of i can open up a
new session and i can actually change
the editor so if i were a python user i
might be more comfortable and say
jupyter lab or jupiter notebook where i
could use the notebook environment to
write python code and publish those
notebooks to connect if i were writing
say
applications like streamlink dash or
flask i might be more comfortable in vs
code which is a great editor for
python as well as things like javascript
and some other languages so those are
also available to be opened up through
our studio
there was a question in the chat
in terms of using additional clusters so
this environment is run in this hosted
evaluation is run in aws in a single
environment so it only has access to
that local cluster
if you did have something like an
elastic cluster externally to that
something like kubernetes or slurm you
could also launch sessions that are
running in that elastic environment
so that is an option uh if you were
running it on premise or in your own
private cloud for the hosted evaluation
you are limited to this local
environment or local cluster
so let's start up the jupiter notebook
and that hops us right into jupiter
notebook
there's a welcome to jupiter that we can
go into that has some
a little ipython notebook that we can
open up
and now we're directly into a jupiter
notebook and it's you know pre-filled
with some codes you can play around here
you can run the different
lines and create some
plots and things but just showing you
that all the different plots and assets
that you're working with work inside our
studio
so we've shown our studio we've shown
jupiter notebooks and let's just for fun
we'll show a vs code session as well
because i know a lot of folks that i
worked with previously that were using
python really liked vs code
so here hopping in directly into vs code
again it's kind of just vs code as it is
you can install some of the extensions
that you want or customize it to how you
see fit
and we include a little environment so
let's go to
uh
we'll open up a file here
open
we'll back out so
it's mounting my home directory so if i
go to
our studio
i can move to
this files over here and you can see the
welcome to vs code here on the left is
where you would actually log in to
click and then you could actually access
some of the example code that's included
in the hosted evaluation
all right
so we've shown our studio we've sewn
jupiter we've shown uh kind of a lot of
different things going on so let's go
back to the home page you can see i
still have all these different sessions
open and that's part of the power in
terms of like i've logged in one time my
one environment that i have to log into
i've been authenticated and now i have
access to all these different coding
environments
where i can do python natively i can do
python natively in jupiter vs code and i
can do all my artwork inside our studio
the ide
so let's hop into the ide and we'll go
into a few different projects
so we can start off with say an r
markdown
that's one of my favorite packages in r
and it's very powerful
you can see i've uploaded a file here
that actually hasn't been expanded so
let's go ahead and untar
this bundle
so i open up this bundle file and that
will actually
open up these different portions and i
have our markdown as well as a manifest
file some data and the art project i'm
working with
look over at the chat real quick i see a
couple things coming in
disable certain types of environments
where say jupiter notebooks are already
available in their systems yeah so
uh there's a good question about are all
these mandatory you know if you just
wanted to use our studio workbench for
our studio that's more than fine you
know say you have a jupiter hub instance
or something else and that's where
you're using jupiter that's great
part of what we're trying to solve here
is having kind of an entire workbench
and that's why it was rebranded from our
studio server pro to our studio
workbench is because we're trying to
serve different personas here so not
only are but r and python together
for a lot of the it teams they wanted to
manage one environment as opposed to
managing
three or four different custom
environments now from an it perspective
this is lower amount of work for them
because they're managing just our studio
workbench that has all the different
environments in one place
so as far as these uh you know files so
i've opened up in our markdown files
what i'm doing here so let's go ahead
and you know open up the our markdown
it's a pretty traditional one and it
says i've got some packages i need to
install and that's more than fine you
can install the packages you'd like to
see in here so let's say i wanted to
install flex dashboard
i can install the flex dashboard package
and even though i'm in this hosted
evaluation i can still install packages
as i see fit
so let's look at other ones that are
available we have blastula deployer we
can install all these packages if we
wanted to
so let's go ahead and do some of that
because part of the benefit of working
with package manager inside here is we
get really fast package installations
so let's install just three packages
that are kind of already available we
can install them
if you've only been working on your
desktop you might be used to really
really fast package installs because
cran provides binary packages which
install very quickly
um
so for
this for for a linux environment like
i'm running here in our studio workbench
packages uh have to be built ahead of
time in terms of that's what package
manager is providing is providing the
linux binary so they install very
quickly so i was able to install those
packages while i'm talking and kind of
faster than i'm talking because i'm
using the binaries from our studio
package manager
so i've written this our markdown
document it's got a lot of python or
sorry a lot of our deep wire code it's
got uh some parameters and different
settings i can do
and say i want to share this with a
colleague
sure i can take the r markdown document
and i can email it or i can put in a
shared drive or something else and they
could you know render it or open up the
html
but for a business user they may not
want to receive it that way like they're
like i don't know what r is i just want
to see the final report
and that's what connect is providing so
once you've finalized your report
you can actually take this document and
with the blue publish button up here
you can take all the documents in this
directory so there's our markdown report
and email and these returns and we can
create a new asset on our studio connect
so i'll click publish and this will
actually take that document all the
dependencies build everything and
install it on connect for me so it's
basically taken a snapshot of all the
different packages in the environment
i'm working in and it's recreating that
environment for me on our studio connect
so now again in the time it took me to
tell you about it i now have a url that
i can share with my colleagues and i can
limit access or grant access based on
how secure i want to be
for today's example let's say that i
want to show this to y'all so i can
actually copy this link that i just
created
and we can paste it here and you could
actually go to this asset that i just
created
um
[Music]
now i open up the sharing settings so it
kind of opens it up inside connect and
this is our first kind of foray into
connect we publish something so it pulls
it up here and we can look at it and it
defaults to making it where only i or
the specific user published it can see
it
as the publisher i have the ability to
change these sharing settings so maybe i
want to make it available to anyone
within my organization as long as they
can log in they can see this asset or
what i just did is actually make it
public so anyone with this url can open
it
that's not typical in terms of most of
the time you don't want to make things
fully available to the entire world but
maybe there's some cases where you might
want to do that
if i were to limit it to specific users
or groups this is pulling in from my
authentication so i don't have to go
around creating groups in one thing and
creating groups in another thing
whatever your it team is using for
authentication can most likely integrate
with our studio connect and then you can
use that existing authentication to
bring in the users or groups from there
the other component is this is a
parameterized our markdown
so while it's showing one example for
you know this code it's got you know a
nice interactive graphic and some
interactive graphics down here
it also
connect can handle those parameters
inside it natively so for your business
users they can come in here and change
parameters
and re-run the report so they don't have
to go ask you hey um i saw you generate
this report can you generate a new
version for me and then they wait and
then you send them a new one and you
have this back and forth they can
actually answer some of their own
questions and generate a new report or
new asset
very quickly here
so they can actually rerun and kind of
create the new parameters as they see
fit they can either save that or just
view it and look at it or email it to
themselves if they wanted to so i could
send a copy of this to myself or to
collaborators after i've changed some of
these parameters
so let's save this as
more aggressive
and again i have the ability to make
this available for me or for anyone who
accesses this document let's just say i
want to keep it for me and now i have
two different versions of the same
report
and i can flip between the default or
this one i've saved as the more
aggressive version of this portfolio
something else that's really exciting in
terms of what this can provide is i can
schedule this document because i publish
it with the source code and because
connect is a data science platform
it can actually re-execute r and python
code so this our markdown maybe i want
to run this every day so again rather
than me having to manually generate a
report manually send an email manually
change parameters i can just have this
report update in place every day at a
specific time
so 10 26 am
let's not do that i want it to run
really early because i my boss comes in
at 6 30 and i want to make sure that
it's available for her so she can see it
uh whenever she comes in first thing in
the morning
and i wanted to send an email every time
it sends so that she gets the the kind
of quick notes in her email and they can
come to connect to see the details as
well
so now i've saved it as a schedule in
terms of this will now be executed every
single day at 5 00 a.m and will execute
all these different things and
regenerate this in place for me so very
very powerful
i'm gonna pause again and see uh it
looked like a some good discussion
happening in the chat and kelly it
looked like there was maybe a question
that you're pointing towards me do you
mind sending that over
so one i see is that for our studio
workbench kind of going back leaving
connect going back to
our studio workbench real quick there's
a question about using multiple versions
of r yes
one of the benefits of using rstudio
workbench is using multiple versions of
r in the same environment
so while this is using rstudio 4.1 which
is you know kind of one of the latest
versions of our studio
maybe i have a project from six months
ago or a year ago that was actually
using like r 3.5 and i want to make sure
that i can actually you know go back to
that environment and work with it
i still have you know project specific
libraries in terms of because i've moved
from r4.1 to r3.5 these packages need to
be installed but i can do that very
quickly because again i'm using package
manager to supply the packages to this
environment so i can install these
dependencies our studio workbench tells
me hey these are missing so let's
install them really quickly
looking at some of the chat questions
while this installs so it's installing
55 packages it's going to do that by the
time i'm able to read some of the chat
messages so that's pretty exciting
um
yeah so another good question was about
you know maybe i want to generate
something that's you know outside of
connect like it's great to have you know
html content but
my boss or my colleague wants to see
something in powerpoint or see something
in word
so um yeah absolutely so we can actually
open up um let's go back and do a new
session while that's loading because i
have my server i can open up a new
session
so let's go to
[Music]
leave the report open up that one
and while my other session is executing
like it's doing all this package
installation it's about halfway done
i'm now in a new environment where i can
you know
do other things while it's occurring so
as a data scientist i can be more
productive because i have multiple
sessions running on a bigger server
and there's more compute available
there's more ram there's more cpu as
opposed to my desktop which is limited
to whatever is there
so the question was about maybe using
powerpoint so yes you can generate
powerpoint documents with our markdown
this one actually
can create one based off of a template
and i can publish that to our studio
connect so let's publish it really
quickly
so i'm going to publish that document to
connect so that you know people can go
to connect from
their laptop and they can go look at it
and they can access the beautiful html
content that i've created or the our
markdown report i've created
but it can also generate and attach a
powerpoint as an email
so this is almost done again very quick
to install things moving across
so now i have a pdf report that's hosted
on rco connect it's got some static
graphics and other things
and if i email a copy of it so let's
just email this version to myself
it will not only attach the pdf but it
will also attach a powerpoint file
so if we go back to the hosted
evaluation i'm in the home environment
here
i can scroll down to webmail and open up
that link
and now i'm in uh my inbox here
and you can see i've got a couple
different emails but this is the one
that was just sent over
and again this is you know similar
information so not only is it able to
embed a gg plot directly in the graphics
inside the body of my email but if you
look at the attachments it's also got a
csv file so in terms of what was the
output from my script it's got that pdf
report
and then it's generated this powerpoint
file i can download that and i can open
it natively in powerpoint because it's a
powerpoint file
and now i have this kind of branded
specific powerpoint file that i've
generated automatically
with you know ggplot with tables with
text then i'm able to generate quickly
into powerpoint so if i did need to meet
someone in the spot where they want to
be
whether that's microsoft office or
if they're comfortable receiving html as
in our markdown document you can do it
multiple different ways
looks like some other
questions
about
bioconductor
so we do support bioconductor packages
in our studio um
workbench and in our studio package
manager so you can actually host those
in our studio package manager and
install them inside workbench um the
managing of conflicts would be the same
whether you're using r or studio or
studio workbench
that's kind of something native to r not
something specific to uh workbench
specifically
as far as using specific package
versions so let's say that we're inside
our studio
if i install
dot packages
and i do d plier it's going to install
whatever is the latest available on
crayon or on package manager so we're at
d plier 1.0.7
if i wanted to have a very specific
package version then i could use
something like the rn package that's
uh renv
and that actually allows me to set very
specific environments that are
recreatable
you don't have to use this this is
something that's optional but this can
allow you to not only install very
specific packages but capture all those
packages at a specific version if say
you were collaborating on a more complex
document
so we've shown kind of this workflow of
writing our markdown inside our studio
publishing it to our studio connect and
then viewing them on our studio connect
as well as scheduling them and sending
emails that's a lot of power right there
and that's honestly a bulk of what i do
and a lot i get value out of is just
automating some of these are markdown
tasks
with you know with our studio connect so
take this document that's doing this
complex script re-run it every day or
every week and generate an output
whether that output is like we showed
here a powerpoint file or it could be a
csv file or even fitting a long-running
model and saving it out to like a
database or to the model collection
um it can do even more complex things
than that though like we're not just
limited to
our markdown documents
so let's actually flip over to
say tidy models real quick
another benefit of uh the workbench
environment is that not only do i have
like all these different sessions i can
open um but they are larger than my
desktop in terms of my laptop may have
like eight gigabytes of ram and two
quarters
my server could have 256 gigabytes of
ram uh and
60 cores you know it can go as big as
your budget is in terms of you can make
a server much larger
for that example let's say i have a
background tuning script that i'm
running so this is some tidy models code
it's uh doing an svm model and it's
doing grid search so it's you know going
across a bunch of resamples going across
a bunch of different parameters and
doing uh this grid tuning so of course i
could just run this and it'll take a few
minutes to execute
or within our studio i can actually
source this as a local job or as a
launcher job
a local job will execute in the same
server environment that my you know
session is running but as a background
a launcher job would launch in a remote
session if you had that attached so say
like a kubernetes environment where
it'll scale up to meet that need and
scale back down
let's start it as a local job first
so when i start this up it's going to do
this background tuning and it's going to
spit out some information as it goes
along
importantly this is happening in the
background so i can still you know i can
still interact with my console it's not
locked up but it's just telling me hey
this background tuning this long running
script i'm running interactively is
happening in the background
and i can actually event like interact
with it and say okay you know it's about
it's on bootstrap 5 of 10 and it's going
through all the different models and
it's telling me that this has been
executing for 30 seconds
so if there is something shorter running
that you just want to run the background
you don't have to publish it to connect
you can run that through our so your
workbench and just run it as a
background job
as far as while this is running there
are some good questions about
databases and database connections so if
i
go to databases on our studio
one of the benefits of using rco
workbench in our city of connect is that
you get access to all of our
professional drivers so this means is
that not only can you use all these
different databases like you know
hive impala [ __ ] mysql snowflake all
these great databases in workbench but
also when you publish content r studio
connect they can then also use those
database drivers so you can use them in
both places and match your dev
environment to your production
environment
so yes the you know you can use database
drivers or connections absolutely in
workbench as well as in connect and you
can do authentication as well if you
have like data level access for certain
databases there as well
so a couple things going on let's go
ahead and close uh email this background
job is still running but let's close
down a few of these things that we don't
need anymore
close this one
and
that should be finishing up in maybe 20
more seconds so we'll let that run for a
little bit
again i'll check the chat
[Music]
yeah so i think that's the last one so
the job is finished now so if i were to
go here it'll say succeeded at 10 37 a.m
that's my local time
and
you'll notice that there's nothing in my
environment
what i did was actually have it save the
output out as a file so when it was done
i don't have it you know cluttering up
my file my uh environment i actually had
saved completely in the background as
well as a graphic
that's a big graphic so let's zoom out a
little bit as well as a graphic looking
at the different parameters and how they
all fit
so just to show you that
not only can you run it as a background
job but your side effects can be saved
so you can save the model out you can
save graphics you can even you know have
an our markdown document in the
background
so some of the other folks might be
interested and say okay well we've shown
a lot of publishing like our markdown
like what about something else so again
let's go to jupiter real quick
i am far from an expert python developer
but i do
dabble in python every now and then
just as you would expect you know i have
a jupiter notebook and i want to get it
on to connect and i want to execute it
on connect
i have the same blue publish button so i
can publish this to rcu connect
it gives me a similar thing saying do
you want to publish with source code so
you can you know schedule it or rebuild
it or you just want to publish the html
content from the notebook itself
i already have a requirements.txt file
so i can publish it and it's already
connected to the rc2connect server on
the evaluation
so i can go ahead and publish this
i've already published it so there's
this existing one but let's go ahead and
publish it to a new location um just so
we can show the full process
so when i click publish it's going to
give me quite a bit of information here
as it goes through and does a similar
process it's installing very specific
versions of the python libraries as well
as using a virtual environment
and a specific version of python
so it's basically rebuilding the entire
environment for me on our studio connect
even though it's python
it's able to do that as well so let's go
to content
here's the document i just published
which again is just a fairly basic
python notebook
ipython notebook with matplotlib some
pandas graphics and then a nice seaborn
swirl here
and just like i did with our markdown i
could schedule this to execute on a
schedule so again for both r and python
i can execute things as needed
and evaluate them whenever i want them
to be evaluated whether that's daily
down to the minute or even as
infrequently as a year so all that's
able to be customized with the schedule
so we've shown a little bit about
jupiter um go ahead and close those ones
down
for vs code um again some people are
like oh yeah i really love vs code i
want to learn more about it other people
may not have used it before it's a
general purpose development environment
so not necessarily specific to data
science but can do things like
javascript or java or you know general
web development as well as using
something like python inside of it so if
i want to i can uh open up you know a
blank jupiter notebook in terms of uh
there are
ipython notebook extensions for
vs code
and i can you know run python code in
here if i wanted to import pandas as pd
it's going to run a python kernel and
start the jupyter notebook
so we'll go ahead and use python 3.9
i can evaluate this chunk or run that
and then i could do you know pd ahead on
a document or something you know i'm
actually interacting with a live uh
python kernel now so i can do like one
plus one
or whatever and it gives me two so i'm
getting actual output out very quickly
by moving into here
now more traditionally uh within a
uh vs code environment um
i could actually go into and edit say
like a dash application or a streamline
application so let's open up one of
those
and here again as opposed to a chipper
notebook where you're doing you know
very specific cells and text and cells
and text to go through things
this is a more traditional dot pi file
which is often more preferred if you're
writing like an application like dash or
streamlit which are similar to shiny
applications but in python
so this is just kind of a bare bones
example taken from the streamlined
server or uh from their examples let's
go ahead and create a new terminal
and i'll also open up
the
readme real quick so the readme has some
information about the getting started as
well as some information about how i
could publish this application
so number one you do have to form a
connection with the server so you'll
have to generate an api key on connect
and you'll have to connect to that
server
publishing streaming applications is
done through the rs connect python
package so if i were to do like rs
connect
help that will tell me a little bit
about the rs connect package and the
different things it can do
and
if i wanted to deploy this application
i can quickly copy this over
and i can say i want to publish this
you know streamlight application to
connect
again it's going to be very quick so it
kind of goes very quickly because it's
using specific packages
and i can open up
that application that i just published
on rco connect and we'll let that load
for a second but this is a streamlined
application that we went from vs code to
connect very very quickly and again we
can interact with it
and you know get the graphic to change
maybe i want to add canada to here or
something
and now i have canada
added to my graphic so again the ability
to do things in rn and python
there's a question in the chat about the
video these videos will remain on
youtube forever so if you do want to
view this later or share with a
colleague feel free to do that
um in terms of like cron like scheduling
for schedule control right now it will
be done either through the rco connect
api
or via the interactive portion here so
let's go back to content
for the jupiter notebook here
we approach it as this way where you
have the ability to do it interactively
and you're just setting the time as well
as more more detail here that's a good
call in terms of like crime like
scheduling
um you know maybe that's something for
kelly to look at in the future but right
now we have this ability of doing it via
the the scheduler portion
the other component in terms of like
we've shown publishing a few different
assets both in r and python as an admin
or as an it person
maybe you want to learn about like how
this server is working so you can see
i've used up you know about half of my
ram now we've run a pretty lightweight
environment because it's again just used
for some of these evaluations
but it tells me a little bit about you
know how much of the computation is
being used both the cpu and the ram
as well as the number of users
connections and other different
information about the server
in terms of viewing the scheduled
content you could imagine that as you
create new assets um it's going to tell
you what different things are scheduled
so i have a pen example a this portfolio
that we scheduled together on this video
call and then the powerpoint example
that we also publish that's going to be
executed every few hours or every day
so you can kind of look at what's coming
up and what things are scheduled and
make sure that they are doing what you
expect in terms of when they're
occurring what's the frequency and you
can interact with them very well
as far as storing uh keys and secure
things that's a great call so if i go to
a different asset i've created
so
a pin
so this is our markdown document that
has a very specific beneficial side
effect
so within connect
i have this thing that's being executed
and i want to pin the code or pin the
data to a file here on our studio
connect
so within the vares pane
you see i have a secret called rstudio
connect key which is essentially the api
key that allows me to interact with our
studio connect programmatically
this could be something else this could
be database credentials this could be a
username password whatever you want it
to be
you could think of it as very similar to
like the
r environment that you use interactively
inside our studio workbench
so if i were to you know
edit r and vi if i already like use this
edit our environ that's uh kind of
similar to what you would think of it as
like you can put things in here in your
r environment and then you can propagate
those into our studio connect and create
this key value pair
um for the rcv connect key i'm using
that so i can publish pins
so this document that i have scheduled
um generates a nice table which is great
you know it looks at some nfl data and
creates a beautiful table that's great
but the more interesting thing that it's
doing is taking that data and then
saving it out as a pin to rstudio
connect
a pin is just any file or data set that
you want to store on our studio connect
so again rather than emailing back and
forth csvs or putting them into a shared
drive or something like that
you can use the
pins package and that will actually
allow you to pull in data sets and share
them amongst files or amongst colleagues
so i can take a pen in this case a small
data frame of this nfl data
and my rstudio my our markdown document
that's scheduled will scrape some data
and then publish it to this file
and so this file i can then access and i
can read it into r by using pin read on
the specific name
so even though this dataset gets updated
very frequently i can read in the file
from the same place each time
if you wanted to
do something else you can also pin files
like
trained models so let's say that long
model training script that we ran with
tidy models i could actually save that
as a rds file upload it as a pin uh onto
rco connect and then it can be used
downstream in other applications
now the last part that i haven't really
talked about that much was package
manager we've been you know alluding to
it a little bit throughout
but what package manager is doing is
again supplying our packages and python
packages to your environment in terms of
the r packages themselves like let's say
d plier
you can install it directly from cran
sure but package manager is serving a r
package binary in terms of it's
pre-compiled and ready to go
so i can install it from package manager
it can be much faster and i don't have
to build it from source which can lead
to
avoiding errors or anything else
package manager also allows me to use
specific versions so i can install not
only the latest from 1.0.6 but i can
also install an older version from say
2015 so if i had a legacy project i was
working on and there was some breaking
change i wanted to avoid i can install
this old package
um
another one so let's say i have um
one with a
system dependency let's see about gg
point two i think consistent tendencies
no
uh kelly if you can think of one with a
system dependency let's think about that
so period color space
what i'm trying to show here is that it
also shows you uh system dependencies in
terms of for your admins your it admin
they're like i don't know what r is but
what do i have to install to make it
work
so for specific packages they might have
system prerequisites that have to be
installed in the environment and you can
install those in connect and workbench
so that all the packages work as
intended
um so let's say
sf
let's do the sf package
so simple features is a package for
creating
[Music]
maps and geospatial analysis in r and it
has some it's amazingly powerful but
it's kind of attaches to a few different
other system dependencies so you can see
that this one when i go down to these
install system prerequisites it actually
provides a few things that your admin
needs to install
but rather than you having to find all
these from scratch and be like oh i
think you need to install g doll and
some other stuff
your admin can just go in copy this and
then install those globally for everyone
on our studio connect or globally on our
studio workbench
so
um that would be a good example of like
having one with system dependencies that
you can work with there
so we've kind of gone full circle in
terms of talk about our studio workbench
all the things you can do there are in
python our studio connect and all the
things you can do there in rn python
scheduling hosting shiny applications
authentication connecting databases uh
the vares pain and showing some of the
authentication and credentialing you can
do there
uh as well as package manager for
hosting your environments
i'm gonna hop real quickly back into
here in terms of talking a bit about
some of the arguments that people have
to make internally when you're working
with it
and then i'll stay around for a bit and
answer again any more questions as they
come in and chat
so
you know you've you know gone into our
studio team evaluation you've created
something amazing you have these
analyses or tools that you want to use
and you've gotten things off your laptop
like that's the huge win there's like
getting things into a production
environment sharing it across the
organization or embedding it in your
other tools
the other hurdle that we didn't really
mention but because we're solving at the
same time is satisfying it or your
security team and their requirements
so i team security you know they want to
have very specific things they're like
uh i don't know maybe as much about open
source they don't know about r or python
maybe they're linux admins and that's
all they know and that's fine
they just want to know can it integrate
with my authentication and the answer is
yes our studio workbench or ceo connect
can integrate with single sign-on so
things like octa as well as things like
pam or ldap are more traditional
authentication mechanisms
they want to know that your asset that
you've created scales automatically they
don't want to have to go around you know
creating environments for you and
spinning things up and spinning things
down
connect actually handles spinning up new
sessions to meet user demand as they
visit the server so it's handling some
of the scaling for you
they also want to know like okay well
we're working with sensitive data so i
want to be able to audit all the things
that are occur our studio workbench and
connect have auditory and monitoring of
the server resources metrics as well as
user activity so that part can be
mentioned as well
and then a few different people asked
about connections to databases in terms
of um i wanted to actually see things
from like postgres or snowflake yes you
can connect to those and have them work
on workbench as well as in our studio
connect
so that is what our studio team is
providing the ability to get things off
your laptop into production while
maintaining security scalability best
practices
with the open source software you
already know and already are using and
are in python
and in a single platform that can be run
on premise on bare metal servers or in
your virtual private cloud of choice so
like aws gcp azure etc
a very good question came in in terms of
version control and that's a best
practice so i'm actually going to hop
back out of here we're going to go back
into workbench
uh or actually let's go into our studio
connect
and i'm going to show you one more thing
so someone was saying well i have
something on version control and i don't
want to use push button deployment or i
don't want to use terminal deployment
yes i can import directly from git so i
can use an example for today from github
because that's where i have a lot of my
code
so let's hop over to
our studio or
github and
we're going to go full route here so
let's just go to my github will grab one
of the repositories the rcu team demo
and if i were to grab the
url for this
i've got a few different assets in here
i can paste this into
rgo connect
and say which branch i want to use let's
use the dev branch because i haven't
pushed it to production yet and then it
says okay this is the asset that you can
publish directly from git
so i'll title that
git
portfolio
dashboard
and now i deploy this it's going through
the same process of rebuilding the
environment
but
um i
did all of it through version control in
terms of it actually pulled it in
directly and this is the asset i just
created in like 15 seconds directly from
version control
and part of the beauty here is that um
because this was published in version
control connect can actually say i'm
going to watch that repository
and i'll check for updates periodically
so this is kind of a lightweight version
of not quite continuous integration but
semi-continuous integration if i'll use
that term that way and kelly doesn't get
mad at me
but the idea that connect is now looking
for that git repository and saying hey
um let me pull in this git repository i
will build it if i see changes or i can
force it to be built when i click update
now
so i have the ability to publish with
the push button deployment from rstudio
or jupiter i can also publish from the r
console or the terminal and i can also
publish from version control or bring in
something like continuous integration or
continuous deployment if i wanted to go
that route as well
i realized that you know i'm trying to
answer a lot of questions as they come
in but maybe you're like hey
this was not exactly what i wanted the
exact answers i got maybe you had very
very specific questions someone
mentioned in the chat that you can
actually book direct calls or if you
just want to talk to someone one-on-one
we've got lots of different team members
with similar knowledge to myself who can
answer more direct questions by email or
with another call if you want to dive in
a bit deeper on any topic
so hopping back into here again using
best practices things like version
control as well as all the things your
id and security team wants you can build
out these very complex or very simple
assets so this one where you can find at
solutions.ourstudio.com
has examples of like you know pulling in
code with our markdown creating these
data sets as pins that serve a published
api and plumber and then pulled into a
shiny application all being served by
package manager
or doing something similar in python but
now you're using a jupyter notebook and
flask to create your api instead of
plumber and they're being consumed by
say an api consumer or by a platley
dashboard so again kind of full
comparison here between r and python
we've got lots of great reviews in terms
of maybe you want to go read about like
what other people think about it you can
go to trustradius.com
and read all these different reviews
from existing customers and the things
they like to do in terms of maybe
they're doing a lot of python dev or
maybe their core r studio users or they
use rco connect as their you know
professional publishing platform for all
their assets you can read through the
real you know real thoughts of these
people who are actually using the
product
and then in terms of like the complexity
that can be built in here again maybe
you have other things i didn't show
today like you want to use a kubernetes
cluster yes you can use that with our
studio workbench and scale up jobs and
then you know crush them back down when
they're not needed or you can connect to
external databases whether that's like
s3 buckets on amazon or a data lake
running on snowflake
you can also run things like connecting
to tableau and rco connect can actually
host
tableau compatible apis so you can
actually embed
our code and python code that interacts
with tableau
and then it can always do these more
traditional things of like working with
different decision makers so they can
work with shiny or dash or our markdown
reports to influence their decisions in
a positive way
in terms of closing and wrapping up here
in terms of who we are at our studio and
what makes us a little bit different
again a lot of the things we're building
are actually free and open source
software and we absolutely want as many
people as possible to use that that's
what the tidy verse is that's what our
markdown and shiny and uh
tidy models and all the different you
know software that we're creating and
giveaway for free
these professional software kind of
build upon some of that and it allows us
to give away a lot of the software that
we create so if you do need things like
authentication or you're trying to use
shiny in an organization and your it
team says it's a non-starter unless we
have authentication or scalability
that's where something like our studio
connect can come in and solve that
problem specifically for you
specifically in terms of how our funding
works more than 50 of our engineering
resources go to free and open source
software so basically half and more than
half of our engineering efforts go to
giving away software that's free
our pro products fund this ongoing
effort so that we can kind of achieve
this mission of giving away and creating
free open source software
and additionally we contribute to
organizations like num focus uh to
extend our impact in organizations like
python where we're not necessarily
developing as much today maybe we do
some more in the future but where we
want to contribute financially as well
and then lastly something i'm really
proud of is we're a public benefit
corporation meaning that all of our
decisions have to be balanced with the
best interests of the community our
customers the internal employees and
shareholders we're not just here to
improve stock prices
for some company we're here to actually
serve the community and do the best job
that we can at that
in terms of wrapping up as we're getting
close to the top of the hour if you did
want to learn more you can read all
about serious data science on our blog
again these slides or i saw a slightly
different version that i'd publish is
available at this link at the bottom
that i'll post in the chat again
and that has links to everything i
talked about
within the slide deck trust radius
reviews you can book a live meeting or
just send an email to us if you don't
want to talk live that's fine and if you
wanted to evaluate our studio team and
do something similar to what i showed
you today
you can fill out this form we'll send
you an evaluation evaluation as soon as
possible
and then you can do all these cool
things in terms of using the team
evaluation to see what workbench connect
and package manager look like before you
have to commit to anything
um so that's really it for today i'll
try and answer a few more questions as
they come in but we are at the top of
the hour and i know some people may have
only scheduled out the existing time but
i'll stick around for a few more minutes
so that uh you can answer some more
questions
um looks like kelly thank you so much
for answering a lot of the questions as
they came up that was a huge help so
thank you just want to give again kelly
o'brien the product manager for rcu
connect many thanks for her time today
um in terms of seeing what kind of
questions you all have as
community members and for helping answer
a lot of those
there was a good question about
database information
for the
do the database connections need to be
created on rca workbench in connect so
yes because they're environments in
terms of you could create an interactive
environment on our studio workbench so
if i were to go into our studio
and go into my report portfolio
i can form a connection here and it'll
let me you know form a connection with
all these different databases
but that's interactive in terms of like
i'm basically killing off that
connection whenever i close my session
our studio connect is essentially like a
service account where you're actually
interacting with a production code and
so you're going to have to potentially
even use a different login credentials
you might use a service account as
opposed to like my account being thomas
mock's account i would actually use the
like rcu connect service account to do
that
not required to use a service account
but just saying that they're going to be
slightly different and you would form a
similar odbc connection but in a
slightly different way
um
can you close your browser and let your
long-running analysis continue yes you
could set um you know i think there was
a meme on twitter i saw that someone
driving around in their car with a
laptop and the screen open
if this session was going to take a long
time yes you could run it as a
background job and have the timeout be
long so it'll stay open
and these sessions have controllable
timeouts so you can have some sessions
that are forced to die off very quickly
or last a bit longer
the other option and what a lot of
customers actually do
is for scripts that run that long it may
make more sense to run them via our
studio connect
so again while i can kick off relatively
lightweight jobs here like i'm starting
a local job i'll rerun this because it
takes like two minutes if it takes four
or five hours
i could actually build out a workflow
around it and have it be done by our
studio connect so now connect will
handle running the entire execution and
then it will generate some type of
output maybe it generates in our
markdown report talking about the model
fit or it saves the model out as a pin
or it generates an email with
information about it once it's done
so a lot of different complexity you can
build in there beyond just the
lightweight scheduling the new workbench
for the link to the slides again i'll
copy this over
this is the link directly to the slides
and i i heard that there was a slight
difference there in terms of the one i
showed today
and then for a lot of the different demo
assets those are available here
and
a lot
of very cool things on
solutions.our studio
so one more link for everybody
what was the difference between team
standard and team enterprise so that's a
good question in terms of if i were to
go to a
studio team standard and we're you know
live opening something up together
so the main difference in between
standard and enterprise is how many
servers you need for smaller teams they
can basically you use one server like i
have workbench and connect and package
manager i only need one server for those
products
for larger customers we often see that
they want to have
multiple servers and that's where
enterprise is a better fit because you
have as many servers as you want so you
could have like a pre-production a dev
an alpha environment or staging as well
as your production environment or you
could do load balancing across multiple
servers or have high availability so if
one server goes down you have one to
flip over to
um so really standard is where a lot of
teams start in terms of if they just
need one server for everything that's
more than fine you can also add on
individual
server components enterprise is really
just like i want to get as many servers
as i want i don't want to think about
server installs
i can go that route as well
so we're a few minutes over and um looks
like the questions have slowed down a
little bit so thank you so much for your
time today um it was a pleasure to have
this time with you and thanks for
hanging around with me for an hour
again this video will be up on youtube
immediately after i end the call
so you'll be able to access it or
re-watch components if i went a little
bit quickly
if you have any questions please reach
out to our studio
there's a bunch of different links that
i put up in the slide deck where you can
access some of the information i showed
today you can create an evaluation email
us book a live call whatever you want to
do we're here to help out and answer
some questions
um
there was one more question that came in
i definitely want to answer that uh so
our products do come with uh
professional support that's built into
the price
so if you do buy one of the products
that comes with support for uh
maintenance of the our studios workbench
or studio connector package manager or
team whatever you're purchasing
you also get access to what we call
customer success managers that's where i
used to be working before taking on this
role
and that's more of like a colleague or a
peer who knows a little bit about data
science and can help you with like r or
python related questions and i'll get
you in that direction
so again thank you so much for your time
have a great and safe weekend and we'll
see you next time thanks again